bonjour et merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans fit l'écho dans ce magazine nous
allons parler voiture électrique alors
on sait que le secteur automobile
connaît quelques difficultés ces temps
ci en février les ventes de véhicules
thermiques neufs ont chuté de 12,1 pour
cent alors qu'elles ont augmenté de 64%
pour les voitures électriques
alors il faut relativiser on parle ici
de petits volumes mille véhicules sur le
mois
finalement on peut tout voir dans
l'électrique un secteur porteur une
sortie crise pour le secteur
c'est ce que nous tenterons de
déterminer nous découvrirons la ligne
kengo une voiture électrique très
futuriste imaginé en partie par une
entreprise guyancourt toise nous ferons
le bilan de la mise en autopartage de la
twizy à saint quentin en yvelines
nous verrons avec l' ufc que choisir le
point de vue des consommateurs et bien
entendu l'actualité dans le domaine
c'est la sortie de la zoé la nouvelle
voiture électrique de renault
nous voici donc au technocentre nous
allons retrouver le chef de produit qui
va nous accompagner tout au long de
l'émission
aurélien subsol bonjour un jour le
lancement de cette eau et montre la
volonté de renault de s'imposer sur le
marché de la voiture électrique
alors est ce que c'est pour vous
finalement un marché porteur oui pour
nous c'est très important de dynamiser
le marché dynamiser l'offre en proposant
des produits innovants comme c'est le
cas de zoé bien sûr aussi bien en termes
de ventes qu'en termes d'image c'est un
produit très important pour nous quoi
alors les principales critiques sur les
voitures électriques concernent
généralement l'autonomie vous avez fait
des efforts pour la zoé alors de quoi
s'agit-il
alors jouer aujourd'hui c'est un
véhicule qui est homologuée à 210 km
d'autonomie
c'est possible grâce à plusieurs
innovations vous avez l'utilisation par
exemple pour la climatisation et le
chauffage d'une pompe à chaleur
donc c'est une climatisation réversible
qui fonctionne
sur le même principe que les
climatisations réversibles qu'on va
trouver dans l'habitat et ça qu'on sort
à peu près trois fois moins d'énergie
que les systèmes conventionnels
une autre innovation c'est des pneus
michelin energy qui vit à faible
frottement d'un zoo et à l'exclusivité
et enfin nous avons freinage récupératif
de nouvelle génération donc l'ensemble
de ces trois technologies qui sont
brevetées permettent d'augmenter
l'autonomie d'environ 25%
les critiques portent également sur le
mode de recharge avec la zoé il faudra
notamment avoir une borne chez soi la
wellbox pourquoi ce choix c'est un choix
qui n'est pas spécifique à zoé depuis
qu'on a lancé les premières voitures
électriques la fluence ze la kangoo à 2
nous proposons à nos clients comme mode
de charge principale à leur domicile de
laval boxe elle présente de nombreux
avantages
une charge plus rapide entre 6 à 8
heures maximum une charge qui se fait
dans des total bonnes conditions de
conformité électrique c'est quand même
très important
et puis c'est également plus facile de
recharger avec un câble simple plutôt
qu'un câble compliqué qui en boîtier de
régulation au milieu donc la wellbox
permet de charger avec un câble simple
et beaucoup plus léger alors la
commission européenne souhaite restant
d'art 10 et ses modes de recharge
donc pour l'instant les prises en france
sont de type 3 l'union européenne a déjà
évoqué celle de type 2 est-ce que ça va
poser problème finalement pour vous
anciens modèles et puis pour la zoé en
ce qui concerne nos clients de toute
façon on vend déjà des voitures
électriques dans les marchés qui ont des
prises côté bornes de type 2 comme
l'allemagne l'italie ou l'espagne
donc nous avons tout à fait ce type de
câble à disposition c'est pas la peine
de changer la voiture il suffit
simplement si jamais les bornes
française passe au type 2 d'acheter un
nouveau câble ce sera parce qu'avoir la
zoé il ya eu la twizy
c'est le modèle qui avait été choisi
l'année dernière pour les dispositifs
d'autocars taz à saint quentin
alors neuf mois plus tard quel bilan en
tirez je vous propose de regarder la
réponse en images et aurélien sur le sol
on se retrouve dans la suite de
l'émission
la twizy fait maintenant partie du décor
à saint quentin en yvelines
cette petite voiture électrique qui a
fait son entrée en juin 2012 avec un
dispositif d'autopartage depuis une
boutique s'est ouverte à la gare de
saint quentin et des places de parkings
dédiés ont été créés pour renault et la
communauté d'agglomération
les initiateurs du projet le bilan est
plutôt positif
en tout 5 180 abonnés des hommes dans 79
% des cas qui utilisent la twizy en
loisir le soir ou le week end
pas encore de quoi concurrencer autolib
même si les tarifs sont plus bas 15
euros l'inscription pour obtenir le
badge puis 29 centimes la minute pour
conserver un modèle viable des
améliorations seraient nécessaires selon
le constructeur
en premier lieu l'installation de bornes
de recharge
mais renault vise plus une
expérimentation qu'une rentabilité
économique
un moyen d'étudier l'utilisation des
voitures électriques est d'habituer les
consommateurs nous voici dans
l'entreprise akka technologies qui a
imaginé la voiture du futur
il s'agit d'un véhicule électrique la
ligne kengo de nip acheté au bonjour
bonjour vous êtes responsable du centre
de recherche et développement nord de
cette société alors quand vous avez
réfléchi à cette voiture
si vous avez tout de suite pensé à
l'électrique alors en fait oui
puisqu'elle est issue de la première
voiture électrique on a présenté en 2011
à genève
l'astute car qui était déjà 100 %
électrique et 7 links and go est une
déclinaison finalement de ce premier
prototype pour vous
la voiture électrique c'est l'avenir
alors nous en tout cas on y croit en
termes de processus de développement on
a énormément travaillé autour de la
batterie et la batterie aujourd'hui ne
fait pas partie de notre développement
au centre de recherche par contre on
travaille sur tout l'environnement de
cette batterie
on espère et on pense que ces batteries
vont évoluer énormément en termes de
capacité énergétique et donc on a
travaillé sur tout l'environnement
électrique électronique et nous avons
ajouté des couche d'intelligence
à ce prototype qui finalement est un
prototype bi mode qui peut rouler à la
fois en manuels par un conducteur
physique ou à la fois en automatique ou
là finalement la voiture évolue dans la
ville de façon tout à fait autonome
donc elle va pouvoir par exemple ce gars
est automatiquement voilà le soir si
vous allez au restaurant boudé pour vous
arrêter devant le restaurant vous
appuyez sur votre smartphone et la
voiture va directement dans une borne de
recharge automatique se garer dans un
parking
on vous laisse imaginer un objet complet
complètement automatisés donc nous akka
technologies nous avons créé la partie
véhicule et nos partenaires ont créé la
partie borgne et qui pourra à elle seule
charge et plusieurs véhicules différents
c'est un objet connecté on peut dire
tout à fait on a un boîtier spécifique a
été développé par notre nouvelle filiale
mbt qui est effectivement et nous permet
d'être connecté en permanence à internet
et donc forcément tous les réseaux
sociaux et donc c'est une voiture qui
peut être en auto partage via son réseau
d'amis sur facebook par exemple ou autre
ou un autre site alors c'est tout
électrique on pense forcément à la
capacité des batteries
quelle autonomie à l'eau ce véhicule a
une autonomie de 200 km c'est moins que
notre précédent prototype parce que
justement nous avons eu énormément
ajouté d'électronique embarquée beaucoup
d'intelligence qui consomme un peu plus
malgré tout ça reste une autonomie qui
est raisonnable de 100 km pour une
voiture urbaine c'est c'est tout à fait
correct
maintenant on imagine que les batteries
vont évoluer dans les années à venir et
que donc on pourra aller vers des
autonomies beaucoup plus importante
cette voiture est un prototype n'est pas
encore sur le marché
elle était par contre au salon de genève
quel avenir pour les can go alors nous
l'avenir on le voit surtout par rapport
à nos clients on n'est pas constructeur
automobile donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment de montrer le savoir-faire du
groupe akka et ben le cas échéant
éventuellement vendre des briques
technologiques de ce véhicule mais en
tout cas
akka technologies de la commercialisera
pas dans l'état très bien merci beaucoup
merci
ce véhicule a gagné avec trois autres
voitures l'appel à projets du conseil
général des yvelines véhicules
intelligents ville du futur
on retrouve à ce sujet le vice président
du conseil général yves vandewalle
bonjour bonjour alors cet appel à projet
consiste en une aide financière à
hauteur de 1,2 million d'euros
pour vous c'est un moyen d'aider le
secteur automobile en poussant le marché
de l'électrique
oui l'industrie automobile traverse une
mutation majeure la plus importante
peut-être depuis l'apparition de
l'automobile mutation majeure qui touche
les marchés mais qui touche aussi les
produits
on va vers la voiture électrique parce
que elle est beaucoup moins polluante
que les autres voitures
et puis on va aussi vers le véhicule
intelligent l'automobile ces quarante
cinq mille emplois dans les yvelines
depuis la conception jusqu'à la
fabrication la zoé par exemple et donc
pour nous c'est un enjeu évidemment
majeur pour le territoire et pour les
yvelinois
la contrepartie c'est que ces
entreprises restent dans le département
bien sûr nous souhaitons qu'elle reste
dans le département nous souhaitons
qu'elles développent leurs activités
dans les partenaires grâce à ses appels
à projets on sait qu'on a sauvé déjà
plusieurs centaines d'emplois et créer
des dizaines d'emplois de haut niveau
ils vont des balles merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
nous retournons maintenant au
technocentre de renault à guyancourt
or et d'un sous sol donc akka
technologies travaille sur les voitures
de demain ce qu'on est aussi avec la
ligne kengo c'est l'aide des pouvoirs
publics
est-ce que c'est nécessaire finalement
pour développer la voiture électrique
c'est en tout cas important parce que
c'est vrai qu'avec la prime de 7000
euros par exemple en france ça nous
permet de vendre une zoé au prix d'une
voiture équivalente essence c'est à dire
13 1700 euros
donc ça permet véritablement de
démocratiser le véhicule électrique
après plus le marché va se développer
plus on va rentrer sur des économies
d'échelle une économie de masse et on
aura de moins en moins besoin de ce type
dead
merci or il un épisode avant de conclure
cette émission avec vous nous allons
voir l'association ufc que choisir pour
découvrir le point de vue des
consommateurs
on se retrouve juste après jean michel
collon bonjour bonjour vous êtes
administrateur d'ufc que choisir dans la
région de versailles alors pour certains
la voiture électrique peut finalement
permettre au secteur automobile de
sortir de la crise est ce que les
consommateurs s'y retrouver il trouve
dans l'intérêt également le consommateur
il a d'abord une habitude c'est d'avoir
une voiture qui lui permet de sortir à
tout moment de chez lui de faire un
plein à tout moment et de faire des
grandes distances et l'électricité pas
forcément très bien placé la voiture
électrique un rayon d'action qui disons
de 50 à 60 kilomètres des difficultés
pour ré alimenter sa batterie et elle a
un coût qui est quand même relativement
élevé par contre pour le consommateur
qui utilise sa voiture et c'est une très
grande majorité de consommateurs pour
aller de leur domicile à la gare pour
aller de leur domicile à son bureau il
n'y a pas de problème majeur ça rentre
dans le fourchette
en gros la voiture électrique dans un
premier temps son marché ce sera un
marché un peu de niche qui est la
seconde voiture et on va dire pour des
gens qui ont quand même des moyens d'une
part parce qu'il faut de voitures et
d'autre part parce qu'il faut la payer
du coup pour vous
et d'autres solutions alors dans ce
genre de problème c'est où l'ancien ou
le tout nouveau donc la formule
intermédiaire qui consiste à associer un
moteur thermique avec un moteur
électrique c'est à dire l'hybride avec
différents degrés d'hybridation dont le
le full hybrid ou le l'hybride
rechargeable sont des solutions qui lui
permettent de penser qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de venir rien ce talent pour l'ufc
que choisir le marché de l'automobile ne
veut pas se contenter de la voiture
électrique ça reste une voiture
secondaire vous semblez d'accord avec ce
point alors est ce que ça pourrait
changer dans le futur
alors aujourd'hui une seule statistique
87 % des déplacements quotidiens des
européens aujourd'hui font moins de 60
km vous voyez qu'avec 150 km vous pouvez
déjà répondre à 87% des usages
alors après aux voitures secondaire je
trouve ça un peu sévère c'est plutôt la
première voiture du foyer dans la mesure
où c'est celle qui va être utilisé le
plus souvent pendant toute la semaine et
c'est vrai que pour partir en week-end
ou en vacances mais elle va falloir
continuer à utiliser un véhicule
thermique très bien merci beaucoup
son prix c'est la fin de ce fil est qu
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
pour un prochain numéro le 5 avril